hey there kids welcome back to new
rockstars where the channel that breaks
down every single one of your favorite
movies and TV shows and today we're
taking a swing at finding all the Easter
eggs and Jessica Jones season 2 quickie
review it's pretty good and my favorite
season from these Marvel Netflix shows
by I'm fairly consistent and the
emotional beats really hurt me now while
these shows aren't jam-packed with
Easter eggs like the CW DC shows or the
MCU movies there are still plenty of
goodies to find
here's your spoiler warning for the
entirety of the Jessica Jones series the
comics the other Marvel Netflix series
the MCU books you know the drill let's
kick it off with some awesome comic book
references I was able to find but stay
tuned because one complaint of these
Netflix shows is that they seem to live
in a universe separate from the rest of
the MCU like the Avengers events
happened but then we don't get really
any other nods to other heroes or other
events that have happened so far however
this season of Jessica Jones finally
gives us a nod to post-civil war MCU yes
Captain America Civil War let's kick
this off with looking at Jessica's
montage of clients we actually get two
teases here to Marvel Comics properties
one more obvious than the other you all
probably figure out the first one pretty
quickly get it yes cuz the Whizzer is
actually a superhero from Marvel Comics
the Wizards actually been around for
quite some time first appearing in USA
Comics number one in August of 1941 and
while the character in the show is
Robert Coleman the comic-book alter ego
is Robert Frank pretty similar also you
get a nod to his costume in the comics
with the yellow hoodie even cooler in
the comics Robert gets his powers via an
injection of mongoose blood just gonna
oversimplify that entire storyline he
gets an injection of mongoose blood and
that's why he has super speed mmm this
comes back in a really cool way later
but just hold on for a second remember
that woman talking about lizard people
living among us while there are popular
conspiracy theories of shape-shifting
lizard people who have taken over the
bodies of world leaders this is actually
a fun not to a popular alien race in
Marvel Comics and this Easter Egg might
be a fun nod to Jessica Jones BFF in the
comics Carol Danvers aka
Captain Marvel I'm talking about the
scrolls and they're facing off against
Captain Marvel in her upcoming solo film
plus some other alien races but let's
not get bogged down on that right now
back to the reference one of the most
famous scroll storylines a secretive
Asian a storyline where a large chunk of
the superhero community is kidnapped and
then replaced by Scrolls yes pretty
great storyline maybe we'll see this in
phase 4 the MCU bring it back to the
wizard for a second there was a
weird or clever nod depends on how you
look at it to his origins and his father
remember when Jessica goes to Robert's
apartment and finds a mongoose we don't
see it but it's running around making
noises he's got a great to world set up
in his entire apartment well yeah this
is actually a nod to the Whizzer and how
he got his speedster powers in the
comics also the mongooses name is Emil
which seems to be a nod to dr. Emil
Frank Roberts father in the comics who
injects him with said rodent climbing
things hosts inject myself with a rat
boy I don't just use my little rat
closet it doesn't make any sense anyways
moving forward we got a fun nod to a bit
of comic book history that actually has
come true in the Netflix Marvel Universe
MCU you know what I'm talking about with
Gerry Hogarth mentioning one of her
biggest clients being Rand as in Danny
Rand aka iron fist now in the MCU Gerry
popped up in Jessica Jones season one
with no ties to Danny ran but after the
defenders
she's now representing him which is fun
because in the comics Gerry Hogarth is a
main character in the Iron Fist comics
actually his attorney that's fun that
that came into play in the series also
wanted to point out the spider-man
references which you probably got but
just in case they just whizzed by yet
here you go they're like Easter eggs
really they're more like nods since
Jessica and Peter actually went to high
school together in the comics but
doesn't really work no sense of the age
difference but anyways first we get the
great power comes great Mental Illness
line now this wasn't actually used in
spider-man homecoming but it's used many
different times and the other two
reboots of the spider-man franchise we
all know it we all love it also Trish's
boyfriend Griffin says that he's got a
grody sense which is clearly about to
the spidey sense however I'm not a fan
of having to think about this man's
testicles anywho we also see the return
of will Simpson aka nuke from season 1
now in the comics he's a product of the
weapon Plus program same program that
has ties to Captain America's origins
and Wolverine just a little bit his
first appearance was actually in
daredevil volume 1 number 232 in July of
1986 now here's a fun fact actually in
the Ultimate Universe for Marvel we
actually see that nuke is a product of
experimenting to try to recreate the
Captain America Super Soldier Serum
during Vietnam so he's like the Captain
America of the Vietnam era also speaking
of Captain America we get a name drop
and we see his little toy look how cute
he is also there's a mention of his
shield missing and they had to replace
it could this be a nod to the future of
the MCU maybe I'll talk about it more
later stay tuned I also want to point
out the psychotherapist the
Trish and just visit dr. Thibault in the
comics he actually plays a very low
ranking but fun looking villain named
ringmaster and he first appeared in
Incredible Hulk number three in
September of 1962 will he get his
costume in the show
probably not I'd want stilt man first we
got a tease of stilt man in season 1 a
daredevil I want to see him again
then moving forward to that magazine
cover we saw with Malcolm and Trish on
the cover pretty interesting he looked
pretty believable but uh look at that
side banner over there notice the names
you see right there at the very top
you'll see the name Hedy Wolfe clashes
with galpão and a fun fact Patsy and
Hedy shared a comic together way back in
the 1960s and originally friendly rivals
to one another yay then moving forward
to the painting that Oscar makes for
Jessica this is actually a fun nod to
David Mac was one of the original
artists for the alias comic series he
actually still does covers for the
ongoing Jessica Jones series and he did
paint this painting for the show moving
on Trish in this series seems to have
one too many alter egos in my opinion
it's fun but just a few too many and we
actually get a nod to one that will
possibly see in season 3 we get Patsy we
get Trish and maybe Hellcat soon I'll
talk about how Kat in just a second but
you get a nod to the character with her
clong that dudes face during that fight
outside the gay bar that can't feel good
but hey he's a jerk so he kind of
deserved it then moving forward we see
kilgrave show up yes David Tennant is
amazing in this just want to give a
shout out to killgrave who appeared in
daredevil number four in October of 1964
so he's been around longer than Jessica
Jones has been in comics and you guys
know his powers he can make people do
whatever he wants but there have been a
few changes to his power recently in
comics sometimes he can actually put a
piece of himself in people's heads to
live there forever so maybe this is a
piece of kilgrave's actual personality
manifesting within jessica who knows
also there's a new addition to his power
that he can't really die he has super
healing so possibly he's not actually
dead maybe he comes back maybe he's
hiding out it would be pretty
interesting though if he did come back
in future seasons but hey speaking of
villains let's talk about dr. malice the
man giving people powers after
kidnapping them and experimenting on
them illegally and without their consent
not a great guy but if you notice his
glasses this is actually very fun not to
his comic book history and one of his
personas but really quick he first
appeared in Spider Woman number 30 in
September of 1980 he's usually just the
evil supervillain super scientists in
the comics that experiments on
enhancing them you know the drill but
more recently he had a small run as
carnage yes he actually took over the
carnage symbiote so maybe his red
glasses are a nod to carnage or maybe
just spider-man in general you pick or
even spider-woman hey then moving
forward to Jessica and Alyssa's
flashback episode we find out Jessica's
middle name is Campbell which is kind of
fun but actually in the comics Jessica's
real last name before she's adopted is
Campbell Jessica Campbell and she takes
on the name Jones from her adoptive
family then moving forward to the tease
at the end of the season with Trish
catching the phone on her foot and
kicking it back up to her head we see
the beginnings of Hellcat now Hellcat
the hero first appeared in The Avengers
144 in February 1976 and her powers is
that she's a trained gymnast she's very
flexible she's got she got a good
fighting skill sometimes she has psychic
powers sometimes she can make force
fields but probably in the show she's
gonna have like cat-like reflexes and
super strength but hopefully I end up
liking Trish a little bit more in season
3 hopefully she has a Redemption arc
because right now I'm not a fan of her
and before I move on to the MCU and more
pop culture II reference as I was able
to find on the show there is actually a
very fun nod to a possible new corner of
the MCU if the Fox deal goes through
that was mentioned in this show when
Alyssa and Jessica are running away you
know out of New York you hear them
mention Westchester County which of you
guys know from the x-men movies the TV
shows or the comics that's actually the
home of Xavier school for gifted
youngsters now this isn't really a
concrete not to the x-men since this is
actually just a place outside of New
York City and also earlier in this
season you hear someone refer to someone
as gifted which some people online are
saying that this is a nod to the x-men
show gifted we do get to kind of sort an
odds to the x-men if that's the most
we're gonna get in these Marvel Netflix
shows I'll take it well let's wind it
back for a second and talk about some
MCU and pop-culture references first up
let's talk about in the first episode
where Trish mentions the other names of
the other heroes referring to the
defenders so Jessica is reeling from
working with the defenders and season
one of our own series being labeled now
as a vigilante or superhero we do get
some fun nods to Finn Jones aka Danny
Rand a few different times in this
series like one of the many times
Jessica is drinking one of the bars if
you notice in the background there's a
few pinball machines and if you pay
close attention one very clever person
online was able to figure out that that
is a game of Thrones pinball machine is
is a fun not to Finn Jones history of
being on game
roans probably that's how he got his
name that's how he got his role his iron
fist we also get a fun nod to Trish's
past as Patsy Walker who was like a
Miley Cyrus or Hannah Montana character
in the MCU with her performing at that
child's party with the wig and she's got
that crazy sequined dress and her poster
looks a lot like a Hannah Montana poster
you know my crazy here looks a lot like
it they're moving back to the cap toy
that we saw earlier that I mentioned
that might have a fun nod to the emcee
or the future of the emcee you notice
that he's missing a shoe and that
someone made him a new one let's take a
look at the newest Avengers infinity war
trailer I mean it seems like a fun nod
right
lost his shield new shield this is
taking place post-civil war yeah I just
think about it and tell me in the
comments moving forward we see foggy as
in foggy Nelson one of the co-stars of
the daredevil series now at the end of
season two of daredevil we see foggy
leave Nelson and Murdock the firm that
him and daredevil ran together to go
work for Hogarth and actually make real
money we also saw him pop up in the
defenders working on behalf of Jerry
Hogarth when he got Luke Cage out of
prison which is pretty cool they're
moving forward to win Trish and Jessica
are working together to find Leslie
Hansen they make it to Leslie's
apartment if you notice on the call box
there's a few fun nods to actors in the
MCU and just one random you know famous
person right here you'll see s Jackson
for Samuel Jackson aka Nick Fury also
just below it you'll see F Jones for
Finn Jones aka Danny grant aka Iron Fist
which is pretty cool also right below F
Jones you'll see our Kelly for art Kelly
I don't think I need to explain that one
too much I also want to point out those
two movies that Jessica and Trish ended
up watching on the side of the building
the first being the killers which kind
of mirrors Jessica Jones with its new
art you know take on crime fighting also
within that movie there's a story of a
boxer was paid to throw a fight but then
he chooses not to and then just accepts
that he's probably to get killed by the
mob does that sound familiar
Daredevils dad also the second film they
watch is called touch of evil which has
one of the most famous you know single
takes in cinema which seems kind of to
be the inspiration for a lot of these
one take hallway fight scenes that we
see in the Marvel Netflix shows maybe
it's a stretch but I think it's pretty
cool
also there's a fun for shout out to this
mystery woman being Jessica's mom Jess
earlier in the season mentions to Oscar
that her parents let her try spin Auto
which is that you know alcohol and then
later when Jessica's breaking into
Melissa's house II actually see a bottle
of that same alcohol on the table which
the camera does
focus on for a while but I didn't catch
it the first time around also I
mentioned this in my trailer breakdown
for Jessica Jones season 2 that the moms
name is an anagram for alias ELISA al is
a but let's move on to the really big
Easter Egg for the MCU the raft
Jessica mentions at first then Trish
mentions that it's an underwater prison
for vigilantes or power people in the
MCU which was introduced in Captain
America Civil Wars now we know that the
Marvel Netflix series are actually
moving forward in the timeline with the
rest of the MCU which is pretty cool
it's the first not that anything has
changed in this universe also worth
mentioning that The Wrap does get a
shout out in ages a shield slingshot the
webseries and in the comics Raph does
exist it's actually a prison off the
coast of New York that houses villains
as well they're moving forward to win
Trish trying to figure out what the
inhaler is made out of we hear one of
the doctors say that it's a plant-based
element that could be toxic for some
people what is the other plant-based
power making you know MacGuffin in the
MCU that we've witnessed before well
there's at least one that we know that
comes from Wakanda so maybe this is a
nod to that they're moving forward we
get the return of Turk Barrett he's
doing well he's driving a Porsche he's
eating some fast food hooray also it's
worth mentioning that he's holding a bag
that says Harlem shake and I did a quick
google search of Harlem shake is a
restaurant that is in New York so I was
a little bummed I thought this was just
a nod to the mean I'm on the internet
too much I'll be honest and finally guys
how could we forget there's of course a
Stan Lee cameo but blink and you'll miss
it in these Netflix Marvel series but
it's actually in the bus terminal when
Jess and Oscar are looking for his ex
and son he's on a billboard for Forbush
& Associates which is actually a fun nod
to his usual Netflix Marvel Easter Egg
as a captain for Bush for the police
department which is pretty cool this is
actually a very deep cut to a comedic
character in Marvel Comics
that they sometimes whip out called for
bush man who's kind of like Deadpool he
kind of breaks the fourth wall sometimes
but he's more like a living inside joke
oh but that's it guys I hope you enjoyed
let me know what your favorite Easter
Egg was from this video or if I missed
anything let me know in the comments
down below or on twitter at only stupid
answers yet about the vowels from stupid
guys please like this video share it
with your friends and subscribe to New
York sirs for more content we do
breakdowns for the MCU for The Walking
Dead for Game of Thrones for Rick and
Morty there's so many you're missing now
go watch all of them right now
again I'm Sam basher and I'll see you
next time